also like you to get back to me if you
don't mind to explain the disparity in
REO rates do you know what an REO is and
oreo are not an Oreo an REO are real
estate what's the O stand for the
organization owned real estate owned
that's what happens when a property goes
to foreclosure we call it an REO and FHA
loans have much higher
arias that is they go to foreclosure
rather than to loss mitigation or to non
foreclosure alternatives like short
sales than comparable loans at the GSEs
so I'd like to know why we're having
more foreclosures that end in people
losing their homes with stains to their
credit and disruption to their
communities and their neighborhoods at
FHA than we are at the GSEs I would be
extremely happy if you'd like to have
you work with the people who do that
well mr. Carson respectfully that was my
day job before I came to Congress so now
it's my job to ask you working with the
people at HUD on this problem so what I
would like you to do is to take this
back to FHA and to ask the folks at FHA
because since 2007 I have been writing
about the problems in FHA servicing I am
a huge fan of FHA I'm a believer in
their mission and I am A champion for
them are you of course I believe in the
mission of FHA are you a champion for
the institution the organization very
much so ok so let me make sure you
understand when a loan that the most
common outcome for an FHA loan that goes
into default is REO there's a conveyance
process are you familiar with this I
know about the conveyance all right so
let me ask you about conveyance what
actions is HUD taking to change the
conveyance process at FHA to address the
loss recovery differential between FHA
loans and GSE loans well again you're
getting
way down and the weeds here and it's
real American people out of their houses
so they are literally in the weeds when
they are foreclosed on understood and
I'm very happy to put you in contact
with the people who deal with that if I
got down on the weeds on every issue
wouldn't get very far okay
I appreciate it but this has been a
problem for years the Urban Institute
issued a major report on this and I will
be happy to send you a copy I appreciate
you bringing to my attention I want to
make sure you let me ask you this
given these problems the outcome is that
FHA is the leading cause of blight at
homes in the United States what can you
do about that do you understand the
relationship between the blight and the
servicing problems I understand that
blight is a huge problem and then it
comes from your agencies in action on
servicing I'm not sure that I'm willing
to accept that FHA is the cause of all
the blight that we have I hope you feel
differently after you read the report
thank you